have a mission not a job i say this to  my students  all the time so many of us pursue jobs i  want to be an actor  that's what my passion is i want to be a  writer that's where my passion is that's  great but what's your mission your  mission is bigger than the things that  you do right if you have a mission you  can have multiple ways in which that  mission expresses itself like acting  writing service you know if you're  sitting there and you're thinking to  yourself what do i want to do with my  life  tweak that question just a little bit  what is your mission in life pursue that  mission and i promise you  doors will open people will pay you for  it